[Music]
i want to congratulate you you are in
the sexiest man alive issue now
thank you you're welcome thank you
you're welcome thank you that's okay we
stepped aside this year so did you
[Applause]
is that funny why did i get a laugh
i don't know i think you're sexy thanks
pal i think you're sexy thank you very
much i'm only half alive though
time gets qualified
do you uh do can you what do you
attribute i mean and i'm very happy that
you're in it but do you feel like yes
yes i belong in the sexiest man alive
issue
well
that's the face that got you in
i do
yeah that's amazing what you can do you
completely changed
yeah there's i it it takes on a life of
its own really
[Applause]
you're like mozart what are you doing
i'm trying to match you oh you're trying
to do the conan oh yeah
yeah that's what you want oh
that's good wow
[Applause]
what if you pulled on it and it just
came off
and then you tasted it and it was ice
cream you look
you look like you're having a nervous
breakdown
block of seagulls
i didn't even realize you were growing
your hair out for anchorman 2 which
people are so excited about
you didn't even know i i heard this was
i thought was a rumor but a lot of the
cast didn't even know there was going to
be an anchorman 2 until will announced
it on this show that's right it that's
absolutely true i know you know we had
talked about it for years but it was
always something that we were into the
idea but nobody was ever kind of making
it happen and um
and then he announced it on your show
and i saw it on the show but i had heard
uh i just got a call saying like watch
conan tonight
and not that i wouldn't have been anyway
but uh but i found out right i found out
that it's one time
that day as did i think uh
kechner and carell as well yeah yeah
they found out well uh i didn't even
realize there's a there was a straight
to video dvd
of outtakes yeah there were so many
outtakes and so many deleted scenes that
they actually just made a movie called
wake up ron burgundy that's when we did
anchorman that is on dvd that's all
different stuff we have we have we we're
going to show one clip from this
anything you can tell us about this
scene well we laughed a lot during the
making of it and i think the hardest
that we laughed was during this scene
which is
uh steve carell was trying to eat
something that was so disgusting that we
just couldn't ever ever get past it
because with this scene was we're going
to get veronica's corning stone and then
will ferrell would just say
by the way brick what is that you're
eating and
and uh and and he would say it was a
used cough or no he said it was one of
those hot dog falafel things with
cinnamon and bacon on top and will said
what do you mean one of those those
don't exist
that's a used coffee filter with
cigarette butts
and we just couldn't get through it
let's uh take a look at this scene from
uh from the dvd wake up ron burgundy
so it's settled we declare war on
corning stone
by the way brick what is that you're
eating
oh
it's one of those
delicious falafel hot dogs with cinnamon
and bacon on top what do you mean one of
those
those don't exist i mean that's a used
coffee filter with cigarette butts on it
well i got it out of the food basket at
the end of the lunch line
that's the garbage can
[Music]
although with the cooking at this place
there's not much difference
[Applause]
i suppose if you're going to set up a
clip it's probably best not to just say
the whole clip before
before you play it
it really gave away all the jokes in
this one it's a clip of why the chicken
crossed the road and then he says to get
to the other side let's take a look
let's watch what i just said